después de las celebraciones la realidad
está a punto de llegar para la nueva
residente del número 10 de downing
street- listas toma posesión de su cargo
mientras la inflación en reino unido
alcanza su nivel más alto en 40 años los
precios subieron un 5 5% en enero hasta
superar el 10% en julio de este año
superando la inflación en la zona euro y
en eeuu durante el mismo período tras el
break city la pandemia la guerra en
ucrania disparó los precios en todo el
territorio especialmente en los sectores
de alimentación y energía en abril los
costes del gas y la electricidad
subieron un 54% y se prevé que esa cifra
alcance el 80 por ciento en octubre
muchos temen que lo peor de los efectos
esté aún por llegar para las familias
más pobres del país temores que atrás
prometió abordar
presentaré un plan audaz para reducir
los impuestos y hacer crecer nuestra
economía me encargaré de la crisis
energética de las facturas energéticas
de los ciudadanos
pero también de los problemas a largo
plazo que tenemos con el suministro de
energía
según bloomberg el gobierno detrás
planea congelar las facturas energéticas
en reinounido una medida que podría
costar hasta 130 mil millones de libras
en los próximos 18 meses aunque no está
claro cómo se financiará la nueva
primera ministra sigue insistiendo en
que recortará los impuestos también
promete suprimir la subida de impuestos
a las empresas y anular el aumento de
las cotizaciones de la seguridad social
de abril para sus críticos es un riesgo
elevado sobre todo porque la deuda de
reino unido se disparó durante la
pandemia de kobe 19 y ahora el país está
al borde de una larga recesión